a lot of that speech we were trying to
put a lot of movement in and not
substrate me circular movement so we put
up with a lot of circular rails up there
and also used a very small telescopic
crane to be able to work on top of the
steps because it's tricky this is a lot
of VFX work around you they're telling
to imagine what's in the background
danny has been above it all literally
throughout this entire battle she's
fought the whole thing from the air so
when she's in the plaza all she's seeing
is her own armies triumphant in the city
that she came to conquer for all the
best reasons and I think the idea of
spreading her brand of revolution around
the entire world is a very attractive
idea to her at this moment in her mind
it's a very ethical idea because she's
not seeing the cost the way John and the
way Tyrion have seen the cost
I knew that speech was gonna be really
important and I spent a huge amount of
time learning it for the first time in
my whole game of thrones career I got
that word perfect pretty no my bridge a
lot
[Music]
being so brutally honest here I was in
Hell learning that speech this pretend
language was literally eating me up I
couldn't do it
and then magic happened I woke up in the
morning went on and it all came out I
was probably fighting not what I was
saying but it was what Danny was doing
in rapid oil vo vo vo on Tina Dara don't
video progeria lat what's interesting
about is that she's been making similar
kinds of speeches for a long time and
we've always been rooting for her and
this is kind of the natural outcome of
that philosophy and that willingness to
go forth and conquer all you're an
amazing
[Music]